des gens qui sont bien entraînés à
l'isolément
en voici une mylène paquette navigatrice
exploratrice conférencière auteurs
bonjour comment allez vous bonjour
servier de mon côté vous êtes des idées
très bien alors oui c'est intéressant de
vous entendre parce que c'est quelqu'un
que connut un isolement c'est bien vous
cent vingt neuf jours si j'ai les bons
chiffres sur l'océan lors de votre
fameuse traversée à la rame
comment vous faisiez pour rsa garder le
moral dans cette solitude là mais c'est
sûr que en étant seul dans une
embarcation agité je pouvais compter sur
la participation d'une équipe où ce jeu
peut comparer aujourd'hui ce qu'on vit
c'est qu'on a des familles des fois nos
familles sont éloignés on peut aller les
côtoyer c'est un peu la même chose pour
moi je pouvais pas les comtois y est
physiquement c'est ces gens là mes mails
est vraiment à garder le moral garder le
cap sur mon objectif à tous les jours de
cette aventure là et ce avec beaucoup
d'humilité que je leur disais que je
perdais ma motivation que je me sentais
ce que j'avais besoin de leurs rêves
donc au début je voulais vraiment être
la fille fort qu'ils étaient capables
tout seul puis plus j'avançais dans sa
traversée leur plus je réalisais que
j'avais besoin vraiment mon équipe au
sol pic ce n'est pas un truc de gros
bras austère truc de c'était une
traverse six d'un travail d'équipé pour
la petite est seul mais j'avais vraiment
besoin
mais ce que vous ne disent pas c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
il ya des gens peut-être actuellement
qui sont dans leurs appartements qui
sont seuls et qui n'ose pas appeler ou
n'ose pas lancer des perches à d'autres
personnes virtuellement évidemment de
peur d'avoir l'air faible mais c'est pas
de la faiblesse de savoir qu'au moment
donné on a besoin de parler on a besoin
de faire telle chose exactement qui
s'annonce courage sa demande de l'audace
de briser cet isolement là parce qu'on
peut avoir eu l'air d'une personne qui
savent s'organiser tout bien tout ça
parce qu'on est on ne sait pas nager qui
on est autonome mais le subitement on
n'est pas dans le même environnement
même si on est dans la même maison mais
il ya plus de cars de stress et beaucoup
plus d'anxiété dans la
donc vaut vraiment pas hésité à demander
de l'aide à demander demandé l'appui de
sa famille ses proches
oui à quelle voie est ce qu'il ya eu des
moments vraiment vous vous êtes dit j'y
arriverai pas l'autre bord le jeu je n'y
arriverai pas pas vraiment puisque même
en début de parcours
donc après deux mois en mer quand j'ai
réalisé que j'étais pas tellement mon
loin encore des eaux canadiennes en fait
que j'avais pas encore dépassé la
dernière ligne à l'est du canada dont je
suis encore sous terre neuve après une
cinquantaine 55 jours avant donc là je
me suis dit plus jamais de l'autre côté
ça fonctionnera jamais 2013 ses potes
bonne année pour traverser l'océan
j'ai eu plusieurs plusieurs systèmes
dépressionnaires qui se sont abattues
sur ma route
non je me suis dit mais on veut remettre
en question l'année et non pas le projet
alors j'ai demandé à mon équipe de faire
demi tour et de rentrer au bercail et de
recommencer la traversée l'an prochain
peut-être qu'on aurait une météo plus
clémente et mon équipe madrilène c'est
impossible du peu pour revenir sur ses
pas c'est trop dangereux
c'est impossible tu dois retourner du
doigt conteneurs amis et continuent
d'espérer et j'ai réalisé ce moment à
l'autre la seule chose que je contrôlais
tutelle peu le vent les marées la
pression barométrique mon équipe au sol
ma famille leurs inquiétudes la seule
chose que je pouvais contrôler c'était
l'attitude que moi je choisissais
d'adopter face à ces intempéries le face
aux changements qui ne sont épousés
d'archange et qu'on est la seule chose
que je pouvais pour troubler j'ai choisi
sciemment quelle attitude il est adapté
à tous les jours et ça s'est passé là
dire mais c'est vraiment très difficile
par faire à tous les jours donc ça
commence par les questions constante
actuellement les gens la maison avec les
questions qui reviennent souvent surtout
de la bouche des enfants c'est combien
de temps ça va durer
dans combien parce qu'on veut que nos
amis nos proches dans combien de temps
ce que le confinement avaient relevé
mais si on se pose cette question là à
tous les matins la réponse est dans quel
état d'esprit on avance notre journée
est d'associer aux questions qu'on se
pose constamment
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas plutôt se
poser la question comme ce que j'ai fait
sur l'océan au lieu de me poser la
question dans combien de temps je vais
arriver de l'autre côté nous combine
kilomètres je vais franchir aujourd'hui
j'ai décidé de me poser
question dans quel état d'esprit
j'aimerais passer à travers cette
journée donc peut-être que les gens la
maison ami d'enfance et des enfants qui
nous écoutent peut-être qu'on pourrait
plus se pose la question comment
j'aimerais me souvenir de cette époque
qu'on est en train de vivre de ce moment
historique et comment j'aimerais me
souvenir de qu'est ce que j'ai vécu
durant cette période vous voyez en
changeant la question déjà il émerge
dans ma tête des choses que j'aimerais
me souvenir de cette période là comme
d'une période où j'ai appris à faire des
belles choses où je me suis débrouillé
où je me suis découverte des talents
donc tout ça m'aide à garder une bonne
attitude parce qu'on m'offre moi même
l'imposant cette question là je m'offre
des solutions pour passer à travers ces
journées là qui sont somme toute on va
se dire quand même difficile parce qu'on
est coupé un peu d'une certaine partie
de liberté waouh c'est très beau ce que
vous dites est aussi l'autre facteur si
le temps notre rapport au temps va
changer dépendent à la longueur de ce
qu'on a devant nous par exemple si on va
voir si on prend notre voiture qu'on
s'attend à ce que ça prenne dix minutes
pour aller quelque part ça prend une
heure ça va nous sembler une éternité
mais si je pars d'ici puis je vais en
abitibi libre je sais que ça va me
prendre cette heure ci ça me prend 7
heures
ça va je vois bien vivre avec ça je me
demanderais pas tout le temps quand
j'arrive là c'est ça qu'il faut
apprivoiser le l'on nous dit trois mois
à peu près c'est à dire que du début il
y aura trois mois difficiles deux trois
mois difficiles
là on est un début mais ça aide soit
aussi se dire ça sera pas éternelle non
plus mais quand même il ya encore trois
quatre bonnes semaines devant nous c'est
pendant trois jours que ça va aller
mieux ce rapport au temps là est
important
vous vous savez que ça vous prendrez pas
un mot à traverser l'océan exact qui
dans ma tête à moi mon équipe au talent
immense et ai dit je vais j'aimerais
pour rentrer un peu dans les travers des
objectifs est quand même des objectifs
que je puisse me rattacher ces objectifs
là par exemple j'avais évalué en 90 et
110 jours ma traversée et du rhône en
turc
quand je vous disais qu'après une
cinquantaine de jours 60 jours environ
j'avais encore quitté la dernière ligne
des côtes canadiennes
j'ai réalisé que mon objectif serait
complètement dépassé je n'ai pas cet
objectif
alors je me suis dit à qui veut ça
paraît un peu banal ce que je vais vous
dire mais je me disais et c'est tout à
fait ridicule parce que je me dis bon
ben je vais avoir voyagé pour le même
prix je vais être resté plus longtemps
je sais vraiment d'issue mandat blague
qui part dans le sud à revenant 15 ça
parce que je veux pas comparer mon
aventure à partir dans le sud mais ils
m'ont gardé une semaine de plus et puis
stable j'essayais de parler de l'humour
pour passer à travers cette mauvaise
nouvelle qui était leur tort de mon
arrivée en europe
donc c'est difficile à faire ça servait
de l'humour mais il faut vraiment il
faut vraiment essayer de le faire il
faut il vous
c'est un exercice qu'on fait au
quotidien on devient pas humoriste du
mans mais ils auront devient pour le
comique de la famille doublant même on
est capable de culte ibis d'essayer de
se regarder avec un autre a fait
observer
regardez un peu la situation de
l'extérieur sans être pris de l'émotion
de l'intérieur en regardant cette
situation de celle des traumatisés
ça aide à dédramatiser aussi est à
mettre en perspective
je voudrais parler beaucoup plus
longtemps mylène paquette c'est à peu
près le temps qu'on a mais en terminale
il ya des accompagnements aussi la même
dans la solitude il y avait foule amusée
qu'il y avait des jeux pas il y avait la
nature dans votre calme et faire la
nature
oui je crois bien vu des oiseaux aux
abus des
vous n'aviez pas comme celui qui sait
qui est sorti de lille l'avait pas un
ballon à qui vous parliez mais vous
aviez j'imagine vos habitudes mais parce
que si je peux fils et la fille
justement tu es le rapport la nature moi
j'étais vraiment chanceuse parce que la
nature étaient amis qui le je sortais de
ma tête de mon écouté et je voyais la
nature je pouvait apercevoir des
mammifères marins
mais là je pense qu'on parlait de la pop
art et leur rapport à la nature va
probablement changer
moi j'ai des traits les gens à peut-être
planter des semences cette année si ce
n'est que trop dur gorvy d'avec la terre
apprendre à nos enfants et vous aller
1-3 pied de balco vais essayer de créer
quelque chose avec cette nature là parce
que c'est ce contact avec la nature le
qui peut vraiment nous aider à part ce à
travers qui on manque de verdure c'est
le prêt en dehors de voir les oiseaux on
attend de voir l'été arrive et on avait
des conflits nés mais apporter la nature
à la raison c'est une solution très bien
c'est noté et notre traversée aura aussi
une fin
collectivement d'être traversée aura
aussi une feinte puis là on peut voir
quand même le mois de mai juin même si
tous ne redeviendra comme avant
on va pouvoir quand même relaxer pas mal
mylène paquette c'est un plaisir merci
beaucoup
bonne suite aujourd'hui merci